in contraband mark wahlberg tries to
smuggle things he doesn't want the
public eye to ever see he should try
smuggling this what no you were the best
of the best family and you got out of
life
contraband stars Mark Wahlberg Giovanni
Ribisi Ben Foster and Kate Beckinsale
Mark Wahlberg's stupid idiot
brother-in-law who is so dumb in this
movie gets caught smuggling drugs he
tries to dump him over the edge so the
person he was sending the drugs to gets
extremely mad that's Giovanni Ribisi now
he wants to kill Mark Wahlberg's
brother-in-law and Mark Wahlberg is
forced to then tried to smuggle
something back in through the United
States to pay for this death of this guy
now owes to save his little brother in
law's blood because he's an idiot
what happened Andy who's running Tilton
and I dumped the back you know I stopped
doing runs you promised me you're gonna
stay out of this and I keep emphasizing
that because his character is so
annoying he's just this little snap you
just wanna just long face I wasn't
really expecting one cent of contraband
I like Mark Wahlberg but this is a
January film and the trailers weren't
terribly impressive for the most part I
got what I expected it's not a great
film but it's a passable thriller I
think it'd be like a really good rental
to be honest it has good moments the
first half of the film actually I found
very interesting and entertaining
two weeks if not I'm gonna come after
the both of you I'll come asking your
wife or you kid I grew up with two older
sisters and so I've always kind of had
this protective vibe about me and so
whenever I see that in a movie like
movie like taken or basically anything
with Harrison Ford in it it's usually
pretty good for me I think Mark Wahlberg
is very good movie but you're not gonna
walk away from a movie and be like yeah
the movie was pretty good but Mark
Wahlberg was probably the weak link yeah
I mean that's not gonna happen the guy
is always a good actor I mean even in
the happening when he spoke the lines
from that incredibly hilarious script
Blackwater Mississippi won't you keep on
shining on me ah good old Marky Mark I
gotta try to fix this trust me I know
what I'm doing what are we running
currency 15 million on four stacks it's
like the size of a Mini Cooper the first
half of the film I was actually into it
I thought that it was a really fun
thriller but towards the last half the
movie really lost a lot of steam because
it kind of jumped a lot of places for
one reason in particular Mark Wahlberg's
kind of out of commission from the story
for a while and I really felt like he
was the anchor keeping the movie afloat
and so for about 20 minutes or so where
his character wasn't involved that much
with the heist and what they were doing
really honestly lost a lot of steam it
made me realize how much Mark Wahlberg
was adding to the film he ever been
convicted of espionage sedition treason
together towards the end it got really
convoluted the plot was just all over
the place certain things happen they
really okay look that would never ever
happen ever ever just why why would you
even consider just mmm but if you're
into Mark Wahlberg if you're looking for
just a you know just a fun time to not
really get that invested in movie but
still keep your consciousness attune to
what's happening
they contraband probably a fun time for
you but I'm gonna give contraband at B -
because I was mildly entertained and I
like Mark Wahlberg in the film so you
know it's not that bad open the
container
and I'm not to dump it in the water you
will never find that money so let me go
down below I'd like to know what your
favorite Mark Wahlberg film is after
thinking about it mine might be the
departed for someone to go from our
early 90s rap Calvin Klein underwear
model to a oscar-nominated actor that's
pretty awesome if you liked this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
steppen eyes talking plastic